thanks alejandro wesley
you had a pretty reasonable day plus one
your feelings about your play and your
form coming so far today um yeah you're
right today has been reasonable
uh but yeah i'd like to thank the lord
for letting me win one game today hasn't
wasn't easy at all in all games uh it's
very difficult first of all
the the thing is in order to win you
have to get a good opening so you have
to survive the opening first uh if white
preferably gets some advantage if you
just get an equal position it's very
very difficult to win
games because everyone here is very
strong
unfortunately the last game went well
but i think the first and second game
was pretty much equal so i can
be i can be pretty pretty pleased with
the results considering the positions i
got today were not very inspiring
you are the de facto leader of the tour
right now even if you finished dead last
you would be you would leapfrog maxime
how much are your thoughts on
maintaining a good result for the tour
as it goes into its last
event coming up well considering the
tours were different this year thanks to
kovid half half the regulator players
cannot finish the events
uh
or or at least would miss one so it's
it's been very weird i think there's
like five regular tour players left
fighting for the top three places
so there's not much competition uh but i
just want to play some some good chess
i think i'm in a very good standing in
the grand gesture at the moment but i
was also in very good standing two years
ago and two years ago and then i
finished last place in the sink field
cup
and for and for and dropped out of the
top three in the granchester ranking so
i just want to play some good chess uh i
understand that i've had terrible
results in in st louis during summer in
the past maybe it's the heat
so i i gotta watch out and and be
careful take it
one game at a time i must say though
that i'm very pleased with this
tournament because
most of my par most of the participants
here are
my ex-teammates and also would be my
teammates in the upcoming olympiad and
also perhaps world team so i'm very
pleased that sam shanklin is here uh
he's improved a lot uh jeffrey shong
uh he's improved tremendously his games
in world open have been very inspiring
also it's nice to have hikaru hikaru
back they can break from twitch and also
fabiano
and lanier uh so it feels like
granchester this year's is an american
tournament but i'm pleased to to spar
and play with my excellent teammates all
right i'm sure they enjoy playing with
you as well except with teammates who
are beating up their their fellow
teammates like this where
sam is smiling i think we're friends out
of the board but we're enemies in the
board but i think uh that's
you have to push because uh
you either beat them or they beat you
that's the truth all right well thanks
so much for joining us best of luck the
rest of the way good question a quick
question for you wesley i've got this
position
where you played against sam and i think
for a lot of people watching you play
and having this position you came up in
my mind with just a wonderful wonderful
maneuver
you found the move
h5 g5 king b1 and the idea
as you executed it was that you put your
queen and bishop on this deadly battery
which eventually brought you victory the
question is in this position
how does that concept how did that
idea of creating that battery because
it's very hidden
it's a very hidden
way of play how did that
take us through your thought process
well i spent a lot of time here actually
i was just as confused as you uh at this
stage because i had so many good plans
e4 or g4
but i took i think six minutes to figure
everything out we got a critical stage
so
i i finally realized knights coming
quickly to c4
but it turns out h5 is good g5
king a1 knight b6 and now bishop b1
and then queen litter is always coming
the point is that
thanks to the bishop player my king will
always be safe
so the black knights look scary
but thanks to bishop player white is
always safe like black doesn't really
have an attack and after b3 i'm just
threatening to take his knight and black
doesn't have any compensation uh
and
and here it's just a very difficult
position for black i don't think i
converted it in the best way possible uh
it got a bit complicated but it was
enough and and here bishop b4 is also
excellent
to post the bishop on c5
it's just hard i think
uh sam's main mistake is he
underestimated this idea but also in the
opening he should have delayed castling
like keep keep the rook on hit at the
time being so i think castle here after
knight i think castle here is quite
dubious
because it gives me a very fast plan so
i should delay castling and play b5
and it's about equal
thank you wesley yeah yeah i think
castle was definitely accurate but it's
hard to
hard to take advantage over the board
wonderful i uh really uh i'm i'm
applause nice really really nice i think
i won and queen
three was very nice i learned a lot from
you after all so you're like the bishop
pair and grabbing
points you're very good
i i'm working i'm working with two guys
you know it's really tough but after
many years many years i i can't even
play a gambit anymore every time i try
to gambit something like what would
yaster think no no grab the pawn or the
bishop
oh it's a secret thank you wesley and
good luck tomorrow wonderful wonderful